Scream 6 is like filled with Easter eggs
including one calling back to Jenna
Ortega's role as Wednesday Adams there
are plenty of behind the scenes details
for us to discuss so let's just get into
it after watching the fourth scream we
were left wondering the same thing Kirby
dies right this was left up in the air
for a while but according to this behind
the scenes picture of Hayden Panettiere
hanging out on set for Scream 6 with
Jasmine Savoy Brown we officially have
our answer she gets stabbed but she
lives Hayden stepped away from acting
altogether back in 2018 after struggling
with her mental health I'm so happy that
this is gonna be like my first project
back she loves the character so much and
she feels it'll make for an easier
transition back into the Limelight for
her I'm excited I'm really excited
Hayden isn't the only actress returning
for Scream 6 either Jenna Ortega will be
here too alongside her on-screen sister
Melissa Barrera it would seem that
Jenna's recent work on the Netflix
series Wednesday had a bit of an
influence on screen six too seeing as
co-director Tyler Gillett recently
teased that we might see an Adams Family
reference at some point the only other
thing he'll say for sure is that it
won't appear on the subway but Tyler
feels that so much of what scream is is
that the real world can enter and exit
this really terrifying experience at any
moment plus the fact that the movie
takes place on Halloween makes it easy
to slip in little moments like that too
as of Scream 6 there will only be two
cast members to have appeared in every
movie the first is Courtney Cox
returning yet again to play Gale
weathers ah
just finished filming scream this
actually makes her a bit of a record
breaker in the horror genre as Courtney
Cox officially plays the first female
character to have returned for six back
to back movies and other than her can
you guess who the other returning Legacy
might be that's right it's Roger L
Jackson who has graced us with his
unnervingly gravelly voice as the Ghost
Face Killer in all six movies so far
let's play a game Jasmine Savoy Brown
and Mason Gooding will yet again be
playing twins Mandy and Chad Meeks
Martin from the fifth film and now that
we've discussed everyone who will be
returning let's talk about someone who
won't be Nev Campbell stepped out
because of disagreements over her
contract which is much to the
disappointment of fans and even fellow
scream alumni everywhere this can't be
real news like this has to be fake Tyler
Gillett admitted that not having Sydney
around would affect the script greatly
but he feels that this is a great
opportunity to really dig into this new
crop of characters and to any fans of
Sydney don't worry Jenna Ortega promises
that there's references to Sydney in the
movie and speaking of references Scream
6 has plenty of Easter eggs in honor of
other big names in horror as we said
before the movie takes place on
Halloween and this opened up the
possibility for plenty of background
characters in costume so if you look
closely at the scene on the subway alone
you may notice a few familiar faces such
as the babadook Pinhead and Jason
Voorhees one character can even be seen
wearing Samara weaving's iconic wedding
dress and ammo belt from Ready or Not
which interestingly enough was actually
the role that made Matt battinelli open
and Tyler Gillett decide to cast her in
Scream 6 and a fellow newcomer to the
franchise Josh segarra was especially
impressed by the amount of Easter eggs
the film was able to include claiming
that seeing all the little Easter eggs
helped to make everyone more excited to
be working on it and another fresh face
to this green franchise is dermont
Mulroney who has been cast to play
detective bayley and if the idea of
having a policeman play a major role
here sounds familiar it should detective
Bailey is meant to pay tribute to David
Arquette's character of Dewey Riley who
sadly left the franchise following his
characters demise in Scream five I can't
tell you how happy I am to be even uh
the role I have in this franchise and
the thing dermont likes best about his
role was being able to follow in the
footsteps of the great David Arquette
although he's also pretty thrilled to be
added to this franchise at this time
when things are starting to take a turn
for the goryer more thrilling action
Dermot Mulroney isn't the only one
promising that scream 6 is going to get
bloodier though Jenna Ortega is too it
just gets more and more gory this sort
of ties in with one controversial aspect
of Ghostface which is that we've never
seen him use a gun before taking up a
shotgun in scream 6. when the
co-director Matt at first heard the idea
himself he responded with what the two
feelings of what are we doing and we
have to do that like he didn't want
Scream 6 to feel safe or boring
emphasizing that he wanted Scream 6 to
be fun and to raise eyebrows this
definitely Falls in line with what Jenna
has been saying all along too I think
that this is probably the most
aggressive and violent version of
Ghostface we've ever seen and this ghost
face isn't only more violent than any
before he's been doing his research what
is this place
Shrine if you look closely at the items
kept in ghostface's Shrine pretty much
all of them call back to previous screen
films for instance you can see Jill's
blue flannel shirt and Billy loomis's
white T-shirt still stained with blood
and corn syrup mixture corn syrup same
stuff they use for pigs blood and carry
but it isn't only the clothing of
previous ghost-based killers that have
found their way into ghostface's Shrine
you can also see copies of Gail weathers
book on display in a glass case pop
culture is the politics of the 21st
century thank you as well as Dewey's
uniform from his time working with the
Woodsboro police so there's another
reason why Scream 6 has been saying this
isn't like any other ghost face you may
have already noticed that Ghostface has
a slightly different design to his mask
this time around being more cracked and
weathered looking than it has ever
looked before well Tyler Gillett felt
that this new mask was one of those
interesting risks and creative
approaches that they took to this movie
describing it as being meta in a
different way Matt stressed that the
design of the Mask was not an arbitrary
choice but wouldn't give anything else
away for the risk of getting into
spoilers so who would have loved that
ghost face like loves pop music Demi
Lovato wrote the song still alive for
the movie and Jenna Ortega and Melissa
Barrera introduced them to the franchise
in pure scream fashion Demi Lovato
this cheery little featurette was later
interrupted with a jump scare from
Ghostface
Melissa and Demi nearly jumped out of
their skin but fans were impressed to
note how Jenna barely even widened her
eyes maybe she knew that there was a
familiar face inside because when
Ghostface removed his mask it was only
Mason Gooding I just really wanted to
meet you a new ghost face calls for an
entirely new setting too you may have
noticed that we've mentioned the subway
like a couple times now well that's
because Scream 6 takes place in New York
New York baby the carpenter sisters have
come to New York to go to school and
Melissa promises this new setting to be
20 times more mortifying because the
city is so busy that when someone is
screaming for help you'll see that no
one will come to their help despite
taking place in New York the film was
actually filmed out of Montreal Canada
making this the first film in the scream
franchise that was filmed out of the
United States would you like to play
so which returning star are you most
excited to see again and were there any
fun Easter eggs you noticed that we
haven't mentioned yet hello Samantha
like make sure to let us know down in
the comment section below
foreign